any of you old enough to remember when
the real estate market crashed in 2008
you couldn't give a house away house
prices dropped some of the markets the
bubble burst there was some dramatic
bubble bursting out there well I'm happy
to report that almost every market has
returned its value home prices are back
to where they were and Beyond and most
major cities in America today the real
estate market is white-hot like 98% of
them there's a few places that have
problems that are not national economy
problems their local economy problems
and you know the micro issues within
that city are screwing up the city but
that's different most neighborhoods in
most cities right now are white-hot you
put a house on the market you get
multiple bids by the weekend most of the
time right now you've got that and that
is driving prices up of course because
any time you've got it's a simple supply
demand economics lesson from the seventh
grade if you had seventh grade econ if
there's such a thing anymore but you
know when there's a limited supply and a
whole bunch of people chasing that
limited supply that drives prices up
when there's an oversupply and not as
many people chasing is something as much
as there is supply drives prices down
it's called a glut in the market it's
pretty simple we know that scarcity
drives price up in other words and when
a market is white hot like the
residential real estate market is right
now vices are generally going up and you
know that is creating a couple of
situations in the real estate world that
we're running into out here and I'm
talking to you about it one problem is
this market watch came out this week and
said 1.6 million homeowners are
predicted to get new home equity lines
of credit in 2018 now that people have
equity what are they gonna do go borrow
it
well that's just stupid but there's 1.6
million people out there they're getting
ready to do something stupid according
to this report
don't go party your equity out of your
house especially on a freaking home
equity loan it's the credit card of the
mortgage world you don't a home equity
loan is it's a good chance for you to
lose your home let me tell you why most
of them have an annual or biannual and
every two two year call in them meaning
the bank can just decide they want all
their money and you have to go get
another loan or have the cash to pay
them off right then or they foreclose I
mean it looks like something in an old
1930s movie or something but everybody
just bee-bop's along and acts like it's
nothing because usually they don't do
that but they have the right in the
paperwork to just decide they don't like
you anymore and call the loan you know
the second thing is you know what the
interest rate on your home equity loans
based on your bankers mood
it's not tied to any index it's not tied
to any national publishing it's somewhat
controlled by competition but you know
when they change they just change it
it's completely variable and it's
variable based on I think we can get a
little more out of Georgia this week
let's just raise it and they just raise
them or they might lower them but not
very often and so you're setting
yourself up in a piece-of-crap loan with
a call and a variable rate that it's
based on the bankers whim that's just
dumber than a rock that's just dumber
you are asking for trouble and then when
things turned down you're gonna go oh
well I didn't think that was stupid cuz
hey when things are going really good
stupid gets covered up stupid can look
smart when things are good but like
Warren Buffett says when the tide goes
out you can tell it was skinny-dipping
when things go down there's a home
equity loans gonna be yeah well where
were you in 2008 I mean were you not
born yet
seriously how did you have no idea you
didn't even look at all you cared about
was I wanted a new kitchen princess come
on shut up
stupid butt stuff don't do that don't do
that don't borrow this equity out you're
supposed to be building wealth in the
ownership of your home not constantly
borrowing it out to buy crap and that's
what your home equity I'm gonna move my
credit card debt over there I paid off
my credit card debt with a home equity
loan see that statement right there's
the dumbest thing I've ever heard
here's why it's dumb you didn't pay off
your credit card debt you moved it onto
your mortgage so you go to the steak
house and eat a steak talk about buying
a depreciating asset on that put that on
a credit card and then when you can't
pay the credit card you roll it over to
a home equity loan then when you can't
pay the home equity loan you put it in
your refinance on your new 30-year
mortgage so now you've financed a
freaking stake over 30 years
this is stupid on steroids and this is
what people do regularly this is a
problem folks it's a problem every time
things get good people get lazy
financially fat sassy and undisciplined
and not watching what you're doing one
of the key elements of becoming
millionaires not borrow on your houses
get your stinking house paid off it's
one of the key elements of becoming a
millionaire all the data points show us
that the citizens stuff I made up don't
go bar on your home equity loan and oh
by the way some of you they've been
thinking about selling your house I
don't know what you're waiting on I
can't you know you're supposed to buy
low and sell high it's high it's high if
you were ever gonna sell a house right
now is the time to sell it right now
this minute jump on line at Dave Ramsey
com click on the lp for real estate get
you on these high-octane high protein
real estate agents and get the sign in
the yard I can do it myself because I'll
just get multiple offers yeah there's a
good way to lose an extra three percent
and three percent of two hundred
thousand dollars is known as six
thousand dollars because you don't know
what the flip you're doing and you're
you know you hire a professional to work
on your teeth you hire a professional to
do your will you hire a professional to
do your taxes and work on your car but
you're gonna sell your largest asset by
yourself
that's stupid don't do that a monkey can
sell a house in this market but that
doesn't mean they did it right don't
hire a monkey don't hire it real estate
they just been in the business for
twenty minutes because they're your
my aunt Jessie just got her license
that's a good way to screw stuff up
right there stay away from aunt Jessie
till she figures out how to you know
like these doctors my practice that's
cuz your practice and still yeah I mean
don't get somebody still practicing get
a professional that's getting it done
that knows what they're doing somebody
sells three houses a year and sold ten
houses in their lifetime that may be
selling you're the largest house your
largest asset and this is time to do it
baby so put it on the market max it out
get the most you can get for it it's a
really good time to sell a house if
you're thinking about moving I've always
wanted we'll do it what are you waiting
on I mean don't wait a little things get
bad this is the time white-hot on fire
get you a white hot on fire real estate
ELP at Dave Ramsey come get somebody
knows what they're doing it sells 50 60
80 100 houses a year knows what the flip
they're doing maximize the asset and for
God's sakes don't go take out a home
equity loan on a stupid thing
hope that's helpful because I don't like
to be unclear this is the Dave Ramsey
show